from The Washington Post inside the
Civil Rights Campaign to get big Tech to
fight the big lie for months civil
rights groups have unsuccessfully
pleaded with big tech companies to
bolster their election policies
correction a group of activists are
lying about what individuals have said
and what they believe in an effort to
get their political Rivals banned and
the problem is no matter how many times
they say it YouTube looks at the content
and goes they're not breaking the rules
so right now I have to wonder about us
being Shadow banned and I think we are
um you know the weird thing is our clips
that we post from this show are doing
really really well they're doing better
than ever and the live show seems to not
they're not sending out notifications
for it a lot of people try to justify
this saying oh well you know maybe
you're posting too many clips now we're
doing the exact same thing we've always
done yeah we do like four Clips per day
and then we do the show they're not
sharing the show so if you want to help
us fight back against censorship because
there's nothing they can do share the
video be the notification it's the best
we can do otherwise they win
so here's what happens I get I get hit
up by uh some journalists from The
Washington Post we talked about it a
little bit they mentioned Jack besobic
they mentioned me they mentioned a few
other people and they claim that we Rose
to prominence in 2022 pushing the big
lie incredible they email me this is
fascinating and this woman is like so uh
you're you're included on a list of 77
individuals who have who have claimed
Biden hasn't won fairly and I was like
when did I claim Biden didn't win fairly
pretty sure I'm constantly saying Biden
did win and uh been ragged on by Trump
supporters for doing so and the left
made a video compilation of me mocking
me for saying Biden one so like what's
your point she sends me a list of tweets
she's like here's the tweets where
you've called out fraud and I'm like
okay and the tweets are like Elizabeth
Holmes committed a fraud GoFundMe
accused of fraud I was like what does
this have to do with the election
and so they include me still in this
story and so what I think is happening
is that YouTube they're politically
biased what I think is happening is we
keep getting these stories they try and
claim that we've broken the rules but no
matter what you like if YouTube took us
down claiming we did I'd sue them in two
seconds for breach of contract because I
know the rules and we did not break them
so what can they do in the background
they can Shadow ban they can do things
like this to suppress the views make
sure people can't see it and then they
can try and appease the activists and be
like oh look we're doing everything we
can to reduce misinformation but they
can't explicitly take action against us
it has to be subversive well and the
other thing is who do they choose to
elevate right and it's not it's not just
YouTube but like if you look at the
recommended videos or recommended
podcasts and the Apple podcast app or
the stuff they're highlighting for that
month I mean have you ever seen a
conservative show up there
why why so uh people have have pointed
this out all the time we regularly will
you know we we had like in the past
month 60 something thousand concurrent
viewers it's political off season in the
20 during the 2020 election we were
getting 150 000 concurrent viewers on
the show never trending like that that
should have been featured as their top
trending live show or one of them and
they just would never do it so like
outright they try and Silo shows like
this content like this now that we're
into the October surprise uh time frame
it's no surprise that we're now hearing
people being like I can't find the show
it's not popping up some people are
saying it doesn't even appear on our
page itself that they have to go to
timcast.com or type in the URL manually
youtube.com
timcastirl live and once again if
everybody who's watching just shares it
and posts the link there is nothing they
can do to censor it Shadow Banning won't
work then yeah YouTube essentially
decides if people will ever see your
content or not and there's many
different underhanded things that they
could do to make sure people never see
you even though you have a large
subscription base even though you're
consistent even though you have a
schedule it doesn't matter I I've been
through it all throughout my entire
YouTube career and they could mess with
you in the search I remember I couldn't
even find my YouTube channel and I typed
in we are changed I typed in exact
titles of videos that I did couldn't
even find it they do it through of
course limiting notifications
demonetizations down ranking in the
algorithm and and of course who do they
promote CNN CBS News horrible track
record horrible organizations that I
don't even call news organizations they
are propaganda organizations that have
been caught multiple times lying on
purpose
spreading disinformation hurting people
with the the misinformation that of
course they spread to the general public
and having a huge negative effect on the
general public pushing of course
partisan bullcrap rather than of course
actual news and the people who do
promote actual news we get we get hurt
by the algorithm since of course there's
this favoritism on YouTube which
evalates uh elevates those voices that
you were just mentioning so I'm curious
what everyone's thoughts are on this but
you know what do you think is the answer
to that because I mean the way I I see
it is
you know you want to diversify number
one and be available in multiple places
lots of places hopefully across many
different platforms but I also think
like you know the conservative movement
you know anybody who cares about Liberty
in this country should get invested in
creating our own platforms and our own
Tech and do everything like let us like
Mao's it let a thousand flowers bloom
try a bunch of different things but like
also build your own ecosystem at some
point for when the day comes with like
no notification notifications go out for
the show right and they totally block
the account I mean I think so and you
know part of me thinks that maybe 10
years ago five years ago maybe even that
would be you know something that would
be possible but it's gotten to the point
where the left has gone on offense so
effectively that like okay you can try
to start your own platform but they're
gonna make sure that you can't Bank
anymore right you know that it's a
really good point because they get to
the root of the internet right like
we're not even just talking about like
front-end platforms now they're talking
about banking we're talking about
servers right yeah they're like your
website can't be hosted yeah you can
accept zero dollars but you can solve
that problem you know with the servers
you know you you I mean you could be off
AWS for example or whatever but the
banking part yeah really really and
they've gotten very effective at trying
that like like they're all their their
entire strategy has moved like you know
you used to be able to be a Libertarian
I think right and it made sense it was
kind of like leave me alone Live and Let
Live but at this point that's not good
enough they don't want to let live they
will will continue pushing forward so
basically at this point you're left with
nothing but like you have to fight back
and what they can't and what they can't
get done through government they get
through done through other institutions
for corporations corporations and other
left-wing entity take a look at this so
I found it on uh so I was on my phone
it's called hit pause and this is the
one of these videos was in my feed
automatically but it was like when you
when you open the YouTube app you can
see like the username the the video and
then the name of the the video Whatever
these have like had like their own
special box let me actually see if I can
pull it up on my phone and then actually
just show you this way because it's
certainly not I don't know just I
wouldn't call it normal how it how it
popped up on my uh my feed it was 2000
so take a look at this yeah it's like it
takes up the whole phone there you go
with a YouTube featured Can you spot the
manipulation learn more this is not a
normal normal YouTube thing and it's
happening right when the election is
going on and are are about to kick off I
mean early voting is starting relatively
soon this is YouTube manipulating the
election hands down big sack is
manipulating the election on purpose
they are interfering but you know what
not I I'm willing to bet there's going
to be like one I'll say I'll say one
maybe upwards of five Republicans who
actually say anything and even if they
do they're gonna sit down in front of
big Tech and they're gonna be like so
you're you're choosing what can and
can't be seen and they're gonna go well
you know we're trying to combat
misinformation and go oh I shake my fist
at that I'm gonna write a sternly worded
letter to you and that's the end of it
then the Republicans are gonna lose
and that and there you go
congratulations so I think uh in terms
of the political uh Arena I think the
important part right now is we're in a
situation where Democrats have the house
the Senate the White House right we need
to take control of at least one branch
and the corporate media and the big Tech
social media and big Tech social media
so ideally in Hollywood you know and I
mean that's that's what in the music
industry I mean that's what we're up
against and the higher institutions of
learning this is getting pretty
depressing
so so the thing is is that we have to
take a majority and either you know want
the house or the senate or both
hopefully that we can get a majority and
that's when we start holding our
Representatives our Senators feed to the
fire because without having a majority
you're just you know what can you do
you're getting a railroad when a few
Hollow roles if you have the house if
you have the gavel in the house then you
have the power to investigate the power
to subpoena right and that's an
incredibly powerful thing to have so
yeah I mean getting a house majority in
particular would be very useful for
investigating some of this stuff though
one thing I would say though also I mean
like look I think the internet has been
great for Libertarians and conservatives
I think the internet is probably the
most democratizing force in politics in
the history since the printing press
right and I think there's more of us
than there are of them and so the
internet is obviously a place where
finally we get to rebalance the teams
right the corporate media is never going
to give us an equal share but on the
internet we have a chance I think the
big problem that we have with big Tech
or you know
you know any any of this stuff this
Shadow Banning and everything is they're
really responding to government
incentives right because you know their
business model is let's make as much
money as we can let's service many ads
to people as we can let's get as many
users as we can the only thing that
threatens that is the government right
and so they're going to respond to those
incentives in a way that says I want to
work with you you know oh yeah we'll
we'll we'll regulate content the people
that you don't like you know we're going
to Shadow ban so you're going to feel
better uh about the content that the
voters are seeing in this country but
you know if we get power
is what what's going to happen you know
are they going to flip around and start
Banning a bunch of liberals no probably
not nope thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there